the revenues and benefits team are
pleased to announce that since April we
have been offering a new service to make
claiming housing and council tax benefit
easier simply telephone us and we will
arrange for a visiting officer to come
out to see you they will complete our
new electronic claim fall for you and
take copies of any documents we need as
well as answer any questions you may
have once they have returned to the
office your claim should be processed
within a few days so if you would like
to make a claim please contact us by
phone on 0170 23 1 h 1 97 or 0 1 702 318
198 from eight am-2 8 p.m. monday to
friday and 9 a.m. to noon on saturday or
contact them by email at revenues at
benefits and the anns is an ampersand
sign at Rochford gov chu chi and i'll
repeat that revenues and benefits at
Rochford golf qk
now we have a piece from councilor Terry
cap more leader of Roger District
Council on Rochford district budget
survey we want your views on what you
consider are the priority services of
your local district council and how you
think the available budget should be
spent your views will be taken into
account when the council considers
considers its future spending priorities
over the next few years watch with
district council like public bodies
across the nation is likely to have to
make major changes to the way it works
as we deal with the reductions in our
funding from central government
following cuts to our government grant
of seventeen percent in 2011-12 our
grant for 2012-13 will be cut by a
further eleven percent this means that
we will need to find a further north
point seven million pound in savings or
additional income for 2012-13 in 2011-12
the council is reducing expenditure by
1.2 million pound which is in addition
to the naught point nine million pound
cost reductions we delivered in 2010-11
some of the tough decisions made for
2011-12 were helped by the feedback
received from the budget survey carried
out in 2010 this identified what
services were considered to be
particularly important and should be
protected from cuts and which services
were seen as lower priority by residents
as they're going to be few easy choices
again this year the council wants to
find out what's important to you before
councillors decide where any further
reductions will have to be made so we're
looking for your views about the
district as a whole based on your
day-to-day experiences and what you
would like to see is the priorities for
services over the next few years please
remember that although the council
provides many services for residents
there are other public service
providers to such as the county council
the police and the primary care health
trust who are all responsible for
providing services in the district in
the survey we have provided some
information about the high level of
spend or for example the income from car
parking in addition to this survey the
cows will also be publishing on its
website an opportunity for you to have
your say about particular service areas
this will give you the opportunity to
make any comments or suggestions about
improvements to services or any
efficiency savings so that you as a user
have identified in addition the survey
will also be available on the website
for online completion thanking thank you
for taking the time to help so where do
we get our money from the district
castle has three main sources of funding
fees and charges for services we provide
for example planning car parking charges
etc this amounts of thirty-one percent
grants from several central government
including the redistribution of business
rates amongst a 26-percent and council
tax amounts to forty-three percent and
who spends the council tax as residents
of Rochford district you can contribute
to funding council services through
paying council tax in addition to the
services provided by Rochford district
council we collect council tax on behalf
of a number of authorities and these are
four percent from Essex Fire Authority
nine percent from Essex Police Authority
two percent from town and parish
councils thirteen percent from Rochford
district council and seventy-two percent
from Essex County Council
as mentioned in this edition of Rochford
district matters there's a chance for
you to have your say about as ending
priorities the survey asks you to select
a high medium or low priority and less
same or more expenditure on these items
tackling anti-social behavior and
environmental crime waste and recycling
public and environmental health parks
and open spaces planning and economic
development support to our community
support to our voluntary sector sports
culture and leisure car parks street
cleaning and litter picking and it asks
which three services in order of
priority you would select if the council
could only protect current spending limp
levels on three service areas it then
asks which three service areas in order
of priority you would select if the
council was going to reduce spending the
very last section asks for details about
you male female ethnic groups and so on
now it may be difficult for some
residents to complete these forms on
their own rochford District Council has
confirmed that if someone finds this
difficult they can call the council on
zero one seven zero to five four six
three six six and help will be available
rochford District Council produces an
annual report which gives an overview of
the counsels performance spending and
financial position the full report is
available on our website but the net
expenditure 2010 2011 was 3.3 million in
respect of making a difference to our
people which included elections local
land charges cemeteries and church yards
and licensing expenditure was 5.3
million for making a difference to our
community that included collection of
local taxes council tax and housing
benefits emergency planning and health
and safety leisure premises sports
development and promotion concessionary
affairs and Housing Services and
homelessness the expenditure was 6.2
million for making a difference to our
environment which included rayleigh
windmill woodlands parks and open spaces
planning and building control
environmental health street cleansing
and recycling the expenditure was six
thousand pounds of making a difference
to our local economy in respect of
economic development and car parks and
it was fourteen point nine million in
respect of making a difference to our
local economy which included net costs
of services less statutory accounting
adjustments including capital charges
less income from cash investments plus
money put into reserves for future use
so the cost of local services to be met
by local and national taxes was twelve
point eight million where did the money
come from the twelve point eight million
that we spent on providing local
services after contributions from
reserves and income raised from various
fees and charges came from local and
national taxes and redistributed
business rates our total income for the
year was 11.6 million which was split
seven hundred and eighteen thousand
pounds government grant 4.47 million
from national built business rates
returned to the council and 6.4 million
from council tax from residence the
council is using balances built up over
previous years to pay for the investment
in the improved recycling service and to
cover reductions in income streams the
council recognizes that these balances
won't blast and has plans to continue to
reduce expenditure over the next three
years and the revenue account surplus
for 2010 2011 the total income was 11.5
million total cost of services 12.8
million and the deficit for the years
1.2 million the council was responsible
for collecting 47.6 million pounds of
council tax last year but we kept only
6.4 million equivalent to 13 pence in
every pound collected the majority of
what's collected is paid to others as
follows Essex County Council 30 4.1
million Essex Police Authority 4.1
million Essex Fire Authority 2.1 million
and parish and town councils 1 million
the average council tax band 4d property
for 2010 2011 was made up as follows
Roger District Council 201 pound and 15
p Essex County Council 1086 pound and
75p Essex Fire Authority 66 pound 42 pa6
Police Authority 132-pound and 12 p town
and parish councils and this figure is
an average figure in its 32-pound 19 p
and the total is 1518 pound and 63 p in
2010 2011 the national average for
council tax was 1495 pound from
government grant and redistribution of
business rates we received sixty one
pound per head compared to a national
average of 79 pound